Good afternoon
everyone, and welcome
to our session of the
Festival of Dangerous Ideas,
We are the Gods, Now.
I'm Ann Mossop from
the Sydney Opera House.
I'm one of the curators of the
Festival of Dangerous Ideas,
and it's a great pleasure to
welcome you here this afternoon
to hear from Jason Silva.
When we were planning
the Festival,
we really wanted to talk about
the future and the impact
of technology on the future,
and because of our experience
trying to talk about scientific
topics, pessimistic topics,
difficult topics,
we decided we really
needed to find
somebody who could talk
about the future of
technology in a way that
was optimistic and
exciting and that
was going to get people to
think about these kind of very
complicated and sometimes
difficult issues
with a positive undertone
to what they were saying.
And we were
absolutely so excited
when we came across the
work of Jason Silva,
and a few weeks after
we talked to Jason
and started to arrange
for him to come,
we found out that he
was speaking at TED.
And I was fortunate
enough to see
him speak there,
introducing a video
he had made for that
conference, and I thought, yes,
this is something that's going
to be really wonderful to see
here in the Festival
of Dangerous Ideas.
Jason is someone who's
hard to categorize.
He's not someone
where I can say,
yes, he's the author of
XYZ, and he's a professor
here and there.
Jason is a philosopher,
a filmmaker, a visionary,
I think.
Someone who, above all,
is a really extraordinary
communicator about science,
about complexity, and about
the future.
So I'm delighted that he's here
to talk to us this afternoon.
Please make sure that
your phone are on silent.
Tweet to hashtag
#fodi, which has
been hacked because
so many of you
are getting so involved
in the conversation
that it became a magnet
to a lot of people trying
to get you to buy
something else.
But we're fixing that,
and Twitter is still
going through, so
don't hold back.
Jason is going to talk to us for
about half an hour, 30 minutes,
40 minutes, and then
there'll be plenty
of time for questions
and discussion from you
because I think this is
something where you will
get a lot of provocative ideas.
So the opportunity to have a
conversation with Jason today
is going to be one of the great
pleasures of this session.
So please join me in
welcoming to Jason Silva.
Wow.
Hi, everybody.
How you guys doing?
Hope you guys are doing great.
We are the gods, now.
What a topic.
Huh?
And I suppose, for me, the
big inspiration behind this
came after I read Ernest
Becker's book, Pulitzer
Prize winning book, the
Denial of Death, 1974.
Pop culture reference
for that books,
it's the book that Woody Allen
gives Annie Hall in the movie
Annie Hall, and
he says, look, you
need to read this so
you can understand
where I'm coming from.
And basically the
Denial of Death
said that the human
condition is characterized,
characterized uniquely, by our
awareness of our mortality.
In other words, we're
the only species
that is aware that
we are mortal beings,
and this causes a tremendous
amount of anxiety.
We would go mad if
we hadn't come up
with solutions to
the death problem.
And throughout
history, Ernest Becker
identifies three main solutions
to the problem of death.
The first one was the
religious solution
to the problem of death.
You create a narrative in which
your soul will live forever
in the kingdom of God, and it
gets rid of the death issue
because everything will be
taken care of in the end.
Now, as technology has
increasingly-- science
and technology increasingly made
religion sort of more difficult
to believe, we've had to
come up with other solutions
to the death problem.
The second main solution
to the problem of death
that Ernest Becker identifies
is the romantic solution.
You turn your
lovers into deities.
She's like the wind.
She's my salvation.
It's the lyric to
every pop song.
She is the sun.
But of course, no
relationship can ultimately
bear the burden of Godhood.
Eventually, your gods
reveal their clay feet,
and all of a sudden, we
can't be saved by our lovers
and the anxiety about our
mortal coil kicks in again.
Ernest Becker says we
are gods with anuses.
We have this capacity
to ponder the infinite.
We're seemingly
capable of anything.
We can mainline
the whole of time
through the optic nerve with
our astronomy and with our space
telescopes, and yet we're
housed in these heart-pumping,
breath-gasping, decaying bodies.
So to be godly, yet creaturely,
is just impossibly cruel.
The last solution to
the problem of death
that Ernest Becker identifies,
he calls the creative solution,
and I think this is, perhaps,
the most interesting one
for a variety of reasons.
Of course, symbolically,
to create a solution
allows us to create
great works of art,
to create work that
will outlive us
and that will
outlast us to leave
a sort of symbolic immortality
and legacy of that sort.
But also the creative solution
to the problem of death,
I think, is the
engineering solution.
It's the way through
which we remake the world.
It's the way in which we
transcend our limitations using
science and technology, and
this gets me really excited
because this is, ultimately,
how I see technology.
Technology is a scaffolding.
Andy Clark, the
cognitive philosopher,
says technology is
our second skin.
Terrence McKenna says it's
the real skin of our species.
Through technology, we
transcend the limitations
of thought, reach, and vision.
We extend ourselves.
We transcend time,
space, and distance.
Technology is our extended
phenotype, as Dawkins says.
It's really what we are.
Our skyscrapers, our
jet engines, that's us.
Just like the termite colony
is temperature controlled,
and it's a part of the termite
species, so to technology
is a part of who we are.
Now, as Ann said,
I'm a filmmaker,
and my background is I
worked in television.
I worked for Al Gore's TV
network for a number of years,
and I fell in love with the
power of short form filmmaking.
I felt that with short form,
you could create content
that could spread,
that could be shared
in the age of social media.
And when I left
current TV, I decided
to create a series of short
films, microdocumentaries,
that look at the co-evolution
of humans and technology
because I feel so in love
with this idea of technology
as a means to transcend
our boundaries that I felt
like this was a narrative that
needed to be put out there
in the world because we live in
this world of doom and gloom.
We live in a media environment
where, if it bleeds, it leads,
and there's a reason for that.
My friend Peter
Diamandis, founder
of the XPRIZE at
Singularity University,
wrote a book called
Abundance, Why the Future will
be Much Better Than You Think.
And in the book,
it talks about how
we have these overactive
amygdalas that we've inherited
from a time where we used to
live in the savannas of Africa,
and it was biologically
advantageous for us to be
really nervous all
the time and always
looking for danger
because it kept
us alive against the tiger, so
that the tiger wouldn't eat us.
And we've inherited
that, but now
we live in a world
that is increasingly
safer, increasingly
less violent.
I don't know if you guys know
the work of Steven Pinker, who
says that the chances
of a man dying
at the hands of
another man today
are the lowest
they've ever been,
or the work of Matt
Ridley, who actually shows
the measurable progress that
we've made using science
and technology and how the world
has actually never been better,
or the work of Hans
Rosling, who has the website
gapminder.org that went viral
a couple years ago because it
showed how every
nation in the world,
by every measurable
indicator, has been rising.
Quality of life has been
rising over the last 200 years,
but we don't notice
this because we
have these overactive
amygdalas that are just
looking for danger, and our
increasingly wired world
is more than happy to
showcase all the danger,
even though it's less than
there's ever been before.
Anyway, promise to go slow.
So I decided that
there was room,
there was room to start a
new conversation about how
we see ourselves and
how we see technology,
and I felt that online video
had become ubiquitous enough
that we could actually
create content that
was short form,
that was infectious,
and that people
could then spread.
And so I started
to do this, and I
created a project,
a series of shorts.
I called them Shots of
Philosophical Espresso,
and the point of the
content is to pull you out
of context in such
a dramatic manner
in order to force you
to gawk in amazement
at the ubiquitous
everyday wonders
that we seem to be culturally
disposed to ignore.
OK, so what I'd like
to do today is actually
want to walk you through a
series of these short films
which will, hopefully,
convince you
that we are on our
way to becoming gods.
The first film I want
to show you is actually
on ode to the power of
ideas, and let's play it,
and then we'll talk a
little bit about the themes.
You know, I love this
idea of radical openess,
the free exchange
of information,
the free flow of ideas,
creating spaces in which ideas
can has sex as Matt
Ridley talks about.
And this is huge because it
turns out that ideas are just
as real as the
neurons they inhabit,
as James Gleick tell us.
A new kingdom rises
above the biosphere.
Denizens of this
kingdom are ideas
because ideas have retained some
of the properties of organisms,
it turns out.
They leap from brain to brain.
They compete for the limited
resources of our attention.
They have infectivity.
They have spreading power.
They are what Richard Dawkins
calls the new replicators, born
from the primordial
soup of human culture.
Their vector of
transmission is language
and electronic communication.
And though ideas are not
made of nucleic acid,
they have achieved more
evolutionary change
and at a rate that leaves the
old gene panting far behind.
You know, Ray Kurzweil
says our ability
to create virtual
models in our heads
combined with our modest looking
thumbs was sufficient to usher
in a secondary force of
evolution called technology,
and it will continue until
the entire universe is
at our fingertips.
This is unbelievable stuff.
It speaks to the telescopic
nature of evolutionary change,
more change in
the last 100 years
than in the last billion years.
Terrance McKenna actually
wrote, "From the moment
that human beings
invented language,
biological evolution
essentially ceased,
and evolution became a cultural
epigenetic phenomenon."
Now, we take in matter
of low organization,
we put it through
our mental filters,
and we extrude it in the form
of space shuttles and iPhones.
The Imaginary
Foundation tells us
that what imagination
does is it allows
us to conceive of delightful
future possibilities,
pick the most amazing one,
and pull the present over
to meet it.
Imagine how
impoverished this world
would have been if
we hadn't invented
the technology of the oil
painting in time for Van Gogh,
or the technology of the
musical instrument in time
for Beethoven and Mozart
to unfurl through it.
With the revolutions
in biotechnology
and nanotechnology, the
free exchange of information
is allowing us to conceive
of radical new things.
Freeman Dyson says,
"In the future,
a new generation of artists
will be writing genomes
with the fluency that Blake
and Byron wrote versus." "What
is great in man,"
said Nietzsche,
"is that he is a
bridge, and not an end."
You know, we're on
a trajectory smack
in the middle between born and
the made, wrote Kevin Kelly.
And so radical
openess, it's huge.
It's a universe of possibility.
It's gray infused by color.
It's the invisible, revealed.
It's the mundane,
blown away by awe.
We need to cultivate
radical openess
as a way of participating
and accelerating evolution.
Wow.
Wow, indeed.
Thank you.
Was that loud enough?
Yeah?
People often ask me
why video, why art.
At the end of the day,
I'm not a technologist.
I'm not a scientist
even though the message
I'm putting out there
is that, increasingly,
a small group of
passionate people,
passionate technologists,
can do what only huge
corporations and governments
could do mere decades
ago, and this is happening
on the back of
these exponentially
growing technologies.
And I'm going to get
into that, but I'd
like to share with you a line by
Marshall McLuhan, which I think
really sums up why I use
short form video to kind
of infect people with awe.
And he says, "It's
always been the artist
who perceives the alterations in
man caused by a new medium, who
recognizes that the
future is the present,
and who uses his work to
prepare the grounds for it."
Now, one of the things that
video obviously talks about
is the power of ideas
to transform the world.
You heard me say that
even though ideas, even
though memes, are not
made of nucleic acid,
they still have achieved
more evolutionary change,
more change than biological
evolution ever did.
And in order to
understand this, you
have to understand that
this change is happening
on the back of these
exponentially emerging
technologies.
Now, exponential growth is
counter intuitive to the way
our brains perceive the world.
See, our brains
evolved in a world that
was linear and local,
but we now live
in the world that is
global and exponential.
Essentially, we have
obsolete brains.
Our brains cannot make sense
of this rate of change,
so we really need to
educate each other.
My friend Ray Kerzweil,
who's a world famous futurist
and has an amazing track
record of predicting
these exponential changes,
he uses a famous example.
It's really simple, but
I think it's important
that people take it in in
order to understand what
makes this kind of
radical change possible.
And he says take 30 steps.
If you take 30
steps linearly, you
go one, two, three, four, five.
30 steps later, you get to 30.
That's pretty simple.
That's how our brains make
extrapolations about distance
and about what's coming
and about the future.
Now, if you take
those same 30 steps,
but you take them
exponentially, you
would go two, four, eight, 16.
30 steps later, you'd
be at a billion.
That's the difference
between linear growth
versus exponential growth.
30 steps, one to 30.
30 steps, one to a billion.
And that accounts for the
reason that the cell phone
in one's pocket today,
the average smartphone
is a million times cheaper,
a million times smaller,
and 1,000 times more
powerful than a supercomputer
that was $60 million bucks,
half a building in size
40 years ago.
So what used to be
half a building now
fits in your pocket.
So the tools to change the
world are in everybody's hands.
The supercomputers of yesteryear
are in everybody's hands.
A young person with a
cell phone in Africa
today has better communications
technology than the US
president had 25 years ago.
This is also out of Peter
Diamandis book Abundance.
So consider what that means.
So it used to be
half a building.
Now, it fits in your pocket.
In 25 years, it'll be
the size of a blood cell.
It'll be reverse
engineering us from inside.
Computers trillions of times
more powerful than the ones
we have today will be
inside of our bodies.
You talk about the co-evolution
of humans and technology,
people think technologies this
separate artificial thing.
It's in symbiosis.
It's a who and what we are.
It's a part of who
and what we are,
and eventually, we're
going to close the loop
because the technologies
going to go inside of us.
I'm very excited about
the three overlapping
revolutions we're seeing.
Obviously,
information technology
piggybacking on Moore's
law, the computers
get faster every two
years, twice as powerful,
half the size, et cetera, et
cetera, they're shrinking.
Then we also have
biotechnology, and biotechnology
means mastering the information
processes of biology,
understanding that our
biology is software,
and that software
can be upgraded.
Just like we upgrade
our iOS on our iPhone,
we're going to be
able to upgrade
our biological software.
The famed futuristic
Juan Enriquez
says you know why this
gets really exciting?
Because when you can master
the information processes
of biology, you
have software that
can write its own hardware.
Computers could never do
that, but biology can.
We have the world's
first artificial organism
created a few years
ago by Craig Venter.
Man creates life.
Man becomes God.
Alan Harrington wrote a book
called the Immortalist, where
he says, "Death has become an
imposition on the human race
and is no longer acceptable,
and any philosophy that accepts
death must itself
be considered dead,
it's questions meaningless,
it's consolations worn out."
Perhaps these technologies
are our rehearsal.
Perhaps by reverse
engineering life,
we have decommissioned
natural selection,
as Edward O. Wilson
says, and now we
get to look deep
within ourselves
and decide what
we wish to become.
Evolution has woken up.
Evolution has evolved
its own evolvability.
As Kevin Kelly said in that
video, "We're on a trajectory
smack in the middle between
the born and the made."
Man is a bridge, and not an end.
The other revolution
we're seeing
is in artificial intelligence.
We create non-biological
intelligence,
sentience that is not limited
by the inherent limitations
of biology, digital minds that
can be endlessly upgraded.
People worry about it.
They think the
Terminator scenario
because they're like, oh, those
things are going to take over,
but those things are us.
They're us.
The cognitive
philosopher Andy Clark
says we need to get over
our skin bag bias, which
is this assumption that only
what is within our tissue that
is natural, and that what we
create is somehow unnatural,
but that's not true.
Technology is an outgrowth
of the human mind.
Technology is imagination
made manifest.
Technology's psychedelic.
The word psychedelic
means mind manifesting.
Terrance McKenna
says we live inside
of condensations of our
imagination, and we really do.
Somebody dreamed of flight.
Now, we fly in aircrafts
all over the world
with our smartphones, devices
made of plastic and metal.
We punch a few buttons,
and we send our thoughts
through time and space,
transcending time, space,
distance.
We're gods.
Another thing that's
often talked about,
and this next video
I'm going to you,
is this idea of mind over
matter because, obviously, this
is used in New Age
bumper stickers.
Oh, mind over matter, our
thoughts can change the world.
But I'm interested in
more concrete examples
of how imagination can
transform the world.
And I love the
writer David Deutsch.
His book, the
Beginning of Infinity,
really turned me on because
he's just totally out there
with his examples
of mind over matter.
So I decided to
create a video that
is demonstrative of just how
our thoughts can spill over,
terraform and transform
the planet and, maybe,
the universe.
Next video, please.
Two, one, zero.
I am very much an optimist.
I'm reminded of Rich Doyle's
line from Darwin's Pharmacy.
He says, "Dreams do
not lack reality."
They are real patterns
of information.
The Imaginary Foundation
says that the role
of human imagination
is to conceive
of all these delightful
futures, choose
the most amazing and exciting
and ecstatic possibility,
and then pull the present
forward to meet it.
That is what we do.
We bring our imaginings
into existence.
But I think that as
technology has advanced,
we found ways to outsource
our mental capacities
to our tools so much more.
Our ability to manipulate
the physical world
has increased in an
exponential fashion
so we've been able to shrink the
lag time between our imaginings
and their instantiation
in the real world.
David Deutsch speaks,
in his new book,
the Beginning of Infinity.
He says if you look
at the topography
of the island of
Manhattan today,
that topography is a
topography in which
the forces of economics and
culture and human intent
have trumped the
forces of geology.
I mean, the topography
of Manhattan
today is no longer
shaped by mere geology.
It's shaped by the human
mind and by economics
and by culture.
So what David Deutsch
extrapolates is that,
ultimately, that will be the
fate of the whole universe.
He says gravitation and
antimatter might only
shape the universe at
its earliest and least
interesting stages.
But eventually, the
whole entire thing
will be subject to the intent
of substate-independent,
infinitely more powerful minds,
and to conceive of that, just--
it makes me feel ecstatic.
That's true.
Thank you, thank you.
I do feel ecstatic
when I contemplate
these possibilities.
Just reveling in those
possibilities gets me off.
I have a mindgasm, literally.
And I started to create
these videos, a part of me,
is just because I'm
a control freak.
I'm profoundly haunted by
the impermanence of life
and by the impermanence
of inspiration.
Inspiration is a profoundly
fleeting and profoundly lonely
experience, and I think
the goal of any artist,
whether it be in paint
or in song or in cinema,
is an attempt to put
people in one's head,
to invite us to smash
our sense of separateness
and to say this is how
the dots connected inside
of my consciousness.
I hope that I can
communicate that to you,
and I hope that you
can understand that.
I'd like to share with you a
quote by Alain de Botton, one
of my favorite
philosophers out of the UK.
And he says-- and this has
to do with the power of art
to communicate, to make
people feel something
as compared to, let's
say, journalism.
So he says, "The artist is
willing to sacrifice a naive
realism in order to achieve
realism of a deeper source,
like a poet who, though less
factual than a journalist
in describing an event, may
nevertheless reveal truths
about it that find no place
in the other's literal grip."
I'm trying to get into
the implications of what's
happening on the back of
these exponential emerging
technologies.
When we reverse
engineer life itself,
when biology becomes
the new canvas
for our aesthetic design,
what new forms of genius
might come out of that?
As Kevin Kelly said
in my first video,
how impoverished
would this world
have been were not for the
invention, or the technology,
of the oil painting, allowing
Van Gogh to unfurl through it?
What new genius will come out
with inventions we cannot even
conceive of yet?
When people worry about
disruptive technologies,
they worry about their jobs.
Half the jobs that
exist today didn't
exist 50 years ago
or 100 years ago.
Most of jobs that are going
to exist 20 years from now
don't exist today.
What new forms of
artistry, what new forms
of human expression, what new
occupations and vocations will
emerge out of these tools
in our ongoing co-evolution
with these tools?
And what I love about using
cinema to convey these ideas
was probably described
best by Gene Youngblood
in his book, Expanded Cinema.
He said that cinema,
like life itself,
is a process of
becoming, a part of man's
ongoing historical drive to
manifest his consciousness
outside of his mind
in front of his eyes.
Now, something perhaps
a little more practical
that we talk about on the
back of these technologies
is the issue of Big Data
and privacy and companies
and corporations and
governments knowing
more and more of our
behavior and being
able to take everything
we do and turn it
into an algorithm that can
maybe predict what we'll
want before we know we want it.
And I was quoted
yesterday in a panel
that I think things like
targeted advertisement
are just engineered serendipity.
It doesn't actually concern me.
I'm more about the idea
of radical openness,
and when I think of
Big Data, I actually
get excited by the new
forms of self-insight
that might emerge from that.
I read recently an article
that said that apparently,
when forager ants hunt for
food, the patterns of how they
do that mirror the TCP/IP
protocols that control
information flow
on the internet.
What?
I went to an exhibit at the MoMA
in New York called Talk to Me,
where they showed me this
graphic animation that
showed the world, and
there was these things
that looked like weather
patterns flowing out of it.
And they were like,
no, that's actually
the diaspora of people
leaving conflict zones.
It looked like weather patterns.
I think what we're finding is
that the more we can measure
in the internet of things,
walking around with computers
in our pockets that are
measuring what we like,
what we buy, where we go, what
we search for, et cetera, et
cetera, et cetera, when
mapped out, when we get
the long view, when we get the
big picture, what we're seeing
is these patterns keep recurring
from the nano to the galactic,
from the organic
to the man made.
And we're realizing it's
all part of a continuum,
and all of it is
nature unfolding.
It's complexity unfolding.
It's just unfolding in different
scales and in different rounds,
but we are of nature.
We feel like autonomous free
agents, going around our lives,
but then the patterns that
work in the organic world
work in the man made world.
You know, I heard
Steven Johnson,
who wrote his book, Where
Good Ideas Come From,
A Natural History
of Innovation-- he
has a lot of great examples
of how he calls the coral
reef the city of the
sea because it turns out
that the patterns of biological
innovation in the coral
reef that make it
the most biologically
diverse environment
in the ocean mirror
the patterns of
innovation of cities,
which are where the
most memes are created.
Has to do with the
diversity and the collision
of ideas and the
amount of idea sex
that's happening in cities
as comparable to coral reefs.
So what does this tell us?
If we want to
innovate more, we need
to create these spaces in
which ideas can have sex.
We need to promote this
free flow of information.
We need to promote
transparency so that we contain
more and more self-insight
into how we work.
And so I decided to
make a video about this.
This is my homage to Big
Data, and I call it--
I was inspired by Isaiah
Berlin's quote, "To understand
is to perceive patterns."
So let's roll that video.
To understand is to
perceive patterns.
Now, of course,
what this means is
that true comprehension comes
when the dots are revealed,
and you get to Steven
Johnson's long view,
and you see the big picture.
This is an idea about
patterns, patterns, patterns,
recurring patterns across
different scales of reality.
You know, Paul Stamets talks
about the mycelial architype
and how the information
sharing systems
that comprise the
internet look exactly
like computer models of dark
matter in the university,
look exactly like the
neurons in the brain.
They all share the same
intertwingled, filamental
structure.
It's the rise of networkism
as Big Data advocates
talk about how man made
systems are looking exactly
like natural systems, and
the more we can measure,
the more we can visualize.
The more we can
visualize, the more it
expands our consciousness by
seeing these recurring patterns
across scales of
reality blows my mind,
and I think that
technology, increasingly,
is becoming an expander
of human consciousness,
and extends our thought,
reach, and vision
and revealing so much more.
It's like whereas once I
was blind, now I can see.
Jeffery West from the
Santa Fe Institute
is telling us that cities
are really like organisms.
Alleys are like capillaries.
How is it possible
that a man made,
artificial,
technological system is
behaving like a natural system?
The more efficient
it becomes, the more
it's starting to
look like nature.
Really interesting, weird stuff.
But it makes me optimistic.
It's like what
Steven Johnson says.
Look, if we can understand
all the stuff, I mean,
anything becomes possible.
It's the adjacent
possible standing
as a sort of shadow
future, a map of all
the ways the present
can reinvent itself.
It's beautiful stuff.
It is beautiful stuff.
Thank you so much, guys.
I love Steven Johnson.
His new book Future Perfect
talks about pure progressives
and the power of peer
networks to solve
problems, which I
think is amazing.
But that last line about
the adjacent possible,
I think that's a great takeaway
message for us to constantly
probe, our adjacent possible.
I mean, don't you
love that, the idea
that we shouldn't look
upon the world as it is?
We should look upon
the world and see
what it could turn into.
Its this shadow future.
We should draw the
maps of all the ways
in which the present
can reinvent itself.
Now, those videos, when
I started doing them,
they were a
noncommercial experiment.
I created a name.
I created an art form.
I called them Shots of
Philosophical Espresso.
Really, it was just an excuse
to communicate ideas the way
that I enjoyed
communicating them,
which is like with this ecstatic
excitement, this attempt
to immortalize and hold in
stasis inspiration itself.
I think it's very
indicative of this idea
that we should not go
quietly into the night,
but we should rage, rage
against dying of the light.
If the purpose of the
human machine civilization
is to transcend all previous
limits and turn into gods,
or as Stewart Brand
says we are as gods
and might as well
get good it, then I
was going to start
by not letting
those fleeting, exquisite
moments of inspiration
go to waste, but
rather I was going
to immortalize them, which is
what I love to do, and then
share them with people
all around the world.
And they've been seen
over a million times now,
and I think it's
indicative that people
are hungry for this kind of
like high level discourse,
but they want it
to be compressed.
They say, I don't feel entitled
to ask people for their time
because I know that
we're saturated in, media
and we have what's called
cognitive bandwidth anxiety.
We just can't process all
the information that's
coming at us, so that's really
the inspiration for this.
But fundamentally, at
the end of the day, what
I want to communicate to
you guys is a sense of awe
and a sense of wonder.
One of my heroes,
Carl Sagan, was
exceptionally good
at doing this.
Timothy Leary, Bucky
Fuller used to call
themselves performing
philosophers.
They'd take these
intergalactic sized ideas
and then use the power
of media communication
to spread those
ideas, to turn them
into self-replicating memes
that can go out into the world.
And this idea of awe as a
kind of reassuring quality,
an ability to contemplate
our own existence
and marvel at ourselves,
as Sophocles says,
manifold the wonders, nothing
towers more wondrous than man.
It's about creating
narratives that are positive.
It's about awakening
the mind's attention
from the lethargy of custom
and the film of familiarity
and redirecting it, instead,
to the wonders of existence
because there are an
unending amount of wonders.
And so I got really
turned on when
I saw this study out
of Stanford that says,
guess what, blowing our
minds on a regular basis
is actually
psychologically beneficial.
Every time we push our
perceptual boundaries
beyond their limits, we are
reborn and refreshed and reset,
and it leaves us with
profound benefits.
So I thought that's cool
because if my videos are
noncommercial shots of espresso
to inspire people with awe,
and now awe is
actually good for us,
why not make a video that
informs you with a bit of awe
while telling you what
awe is and why it matters.
So for my last video, which is
called the Biological Advantage
of Being Awestruck, I am hopeful
that it gives you the chills.
And you'll notice I
speak a lot slower in it
because it's a more
contemplative piece.
I hope that it elicits a
sense of just cosmic wow.
Watch the next video.
Eminent psychologist
Nicholas Humphrey
has written of the biological
advantage of being awestruck.
"How fortuitous," he
says, "for a species
to find its own
ability to contemplate,
to marvel at its
own existence, has
been evolutionarily
advantageous."
In other words, it has
been biologically selected
for because it informs
out life with a sense
of cosmic significance
that makes us work harder
to persist and to survive.
In other words, awe
has helped us survive.
And you know, a recent
study out of Standford
on the subject of awe kind
of validates this idea.
They have found that
regular incidences of awe
leave residual benefits upon
the individual that persist,
such as increased feelings
of empathy and compassion
towards others, increased
feelings of altruism,
and increased feelings
of general well-being.
In this study, they defined
awe as an experience
of such perceptional expansion,
such perceptional vastness,
that you literally have
to reconfigure, upgrade,
your mental schemata
just to accommodate, just
to take in the scale
of the experience.
This is amazing.
We've all felt this before.
The first time we stared
upon the Grand Canyon
or succumbed to the immersive
power of an Imax film.
But perhaps the most
exquisite account
of the experience of
awe was articulated
by the brilliant
Ross Anderson when
writing about the
Hubble space telescope.
Pay attention.
He says that the Hubble
has given us nothing less
than an ontological awakening,
a forceful reckoning of what is,
allowing us to contemplate
space and time on a scale just
shy of infinite.
Wild.
He says gazing upon the famous
deep field photograph literally
allows us to mainline
the whole of time
through the optic nerve.
To fit something so impossibly
large through something
so impossibly small
is incredible.
He says through the
sheer aesthetic force
of its discoveries, the Hubble
distills the impossibly complex
abstractions of astrophysics
into these singular expressions
of color and light, vindicating
Keith's famous couplet,
"Beauty is truth,
and truth, beauty."
Thank you.
That's cool.
You know, even now,
this idea, this notion
that an instrument of
man, a cosmic optic nerve
floating in space can
distill the abstractions
of astrophysics into expressions
of color and light-- I mean,
it just spoke so vividly to me.
I'd like to share with you
one more quote about just
think of the telescope as a
metaphor for what technology
does as an instrument
of mind expansion.
"In it's time," and this
is by Ross Anderson.
"In it's time, the telescope
has transformed the night sky
from a decorated ceiling, a
fixed sphere of glittering
stick figure gods, into
a universe whose reaches
carry the seeds of this
earth and new earths still."
And I'd like to leave
you with one more
line that puts me in total awe.
It's from a website
called Next Nature that
has been kind enough
to feature my work.
They say that
design, and this is
what's important for artists,
really, to pay attention to.
"Design is about to
undergo a paradigm shift.
Today, design starts at
the level of the atom.
We are drifting into the
world of the invisible.
Virtual realities, nano,
and biotechnologies
are increasingly
influencing our aesthetics
and providing new construction
kits for our reality."
And I think the big takeaway
here can be echoed by, again,
the brilliant Alan
Harrington, who's out of print
to work The Immortalist,
I recommend to everyone.
Gore Vidal called it the
greatest book ever written.
And he says, "We
must never forget
we are cosmic
revolutionaries, not
stooges conscripted to
advance a natural order that
kills everyone."
Thank you very much.
Thanks.
Thank you.